so we saw in the last video why if you
represent scheduling constraints among
courses by a digraph that it's critical
that that digraph in fact be a dag and
let's now look at this scheduling issue
represented by DAGs in more detail so
here's a chart of a selection of course
six prerequisites some of them obsolete
but they serve the purposes of being in
a lustral and the little arrows here are
indicating arrows in the digraph so what
this tells me is that 1801 is listed as
an immediate prerequisite in the catalog
for 604 to 1801 is also an immediate
prerequisite of 1802 six double-o one is
and six double O four on both
prerequisites of six oh three three and
604 two of six oh four six and six oh
four six of six eight forty so we're
seeing here this indirect prerequisite
issue that I mentioned before which is
that even though the only thing listed
is a prerequisite for 68040 in the
catalog is six oh four six as a matter
of fact in order to take six oh four six
you have to have taken six oh four two
so six oh four two is an indirect
prerequisite of six 840 so in terms of
graph language and path language a
subject U is an indirect prerequisite of
V when there's a positive length path
from u to V in the digraph that
describes the prerequisite structure
among the classes
it simply means using our notation for
our plus is the positive length path
relation of a digraph or a binary
relation R it simply means you are plus
V which is read as there is a positive
length path from u to V now a key idea
that we're going to be examining in
learning how to do scheduling is the
idea of a minimal subject so the
definition of a minimal subject is a
subject that has no prerequisites no
arrows in a freshman subject so nothing
comes in there are three examples of
subjects with no prerequisites
the chart in the proceeding chart namely
1801 802 and six double-o one let me say
a word about where this funny
terminology minimal comes from it's
because another way to talk about DAGs
is in terms of things that are like
order relations called partial orders
which we'll be looking at shortly and so
you think of the later subjects as being
bigger than the earlier subjects so a
minimal subject is one where there's
nothing less than it now there might be
several minimal subjects because it
might be that neither one of them is
less than the other but there's nothing
less than 1801 there's no other subject
that you have to take before 1801 so
that's the definition of minimal nothing
smaller now you could ask about some
minimum which you are maybe a more
familiar with a minimum means that not
only is there nothing before it but it
comes before everything else it would be
the earliest of all possible subjects in
the indirect prerequisite chain there is
an onion in this example but it actually
used to be one at MIT for a while we
experimented with giving an orientation
week summer assignment that is an
assignment over the summer for newly
admitted students in order for them to
take a subject during orientation week
in which they discussed some book that
they had all been assigned to read
beforehand it seemed like a great idea
to kind of pull the freshmen community
together but it turned out to be
unsustainable because they couldn't find
enough faculty and others willing to
conduct these seminars so MIT started
having a minimum subject so let's look
at the prerequisites again and discuss
how to do a scheduling and the first
thing we're going to do in the schedule
is as I say identify the minimal
elements there are the three of them
that we mentioned and we're going to
start by deciding that we'll take those
three in the first term so we're gonna
be operating basically what's called a
greedy strategy we're gonna take as many
things as we possibly can take at any
term given the constraints so we can
take all the freshmen subjects in our
first term because they have no
quiz says well the next step then is
just get rid of them because they're
scheduled already so we can get rid of
all those occurrences of 1801 802 and 6
double O one not only the there are
other occurrences as well here where
1801 is a prerequisite for things so
they're all gone and we get a simplified
diagram where we've removed the minimal
elements now in the new diagram there
are now things that didn't used to be
minimal before but are minimal now these
are the new minimal elements and we can
identify those here are five subjects
for here and one there that now have no
more prerequisites these are kind of the
second level minimal elements and we're
gonna schedule them next so those are
all the subjects that we can possibly
take on after we've taken the first set
of minimal subjects that the second
level minimal and we'll schedule them in
the next term this is our five subjects
second term schedule likewise well you
delete these guys and you discovered at
6:04 six and six double o for the
resulting minimal ones which is now
possible to take because all their
prerequisites have been satisfied so we
schedule them in the third term six
eight forty and six zero three three by
the same reasoning in the fourth term
and six eight five seven in the fifth
term there is our complete term schedule
obtained in this particular way there's
of course many other ways to schedule it
but this is a particular orderly way
where the strategy again is greedy you
take as many things as you possibly can
take in a given term now there's some
concepts that come up when you're
talking about schedules that that are
worth introducing so one of them is an
antichain an antichain is a sin in this
particular example means a set of
subjects where there are no indirect
prerequisites among them they can be
taken in any order because it doesn't
matter whether you've taken one or not
when you're thinking about taking the
others in a technical language again
motivated by the idea of thinking of
there being a path as though it was less
than or equal to something these are
elements that are incomparable neither
one is less than or equal to another so
in term
of the path relation you is incomparable
to V if and only if there's no path from
u to V of positive length and there's no
positive length path from V to u so
let's look at some anthe chains and the
part of the point of defining it is we
have chosen an t chains as our schedule
for each term so the freshman subjects
with no prerequisites clearly there's no
path among them because there's no path
to them at all so they are in anti chain
the next level we chose were the the
second level minimal elements which
which only had as prerequisites the
original minimal elements and so
certainly none of them was a
prerequisite of the others so that's an
example of a an anti chain and of course
the third level in the fourth level in
the fifth level or anti chains but not
all anti chains are there in our
schedule so for example here is a
diagonal line lying anti chain 6 846
double-o 4 and 603 4 have no pass
between them so in fact it's possible to
take them simultaneously because you
could have taken all their prerequisites
in the upper left here and then take the
3 of them so that's what an anti chain
means here so the technical definition
is no path between any two of them but
in terms of the scheduling of courses it
means it's possible to take them in the
same term if you satisfied all their
prerequisites which it is possible to do
so let's ask about the various patterns
of scheduling that are possible we've
discovered this particular greenie one
where we take as many things as we can
each term but suppose that I was
constrained to only take one subject per
tarma I was gonna I have an outside job
I'm too busy to take more than one class
determine if MIT will let me dawdle so
long that's what I'd like to do so can I
do this yeah well sure just schedule all
the minimal elements first in any order
1 2 3 and then schedule the 5
second-level minimal elements next and
the third level and so on and it's
perfectly possible then to modify the
schedule that we found into a schedule
in which you only set take one
subject per term and of course you only
take a subject after you've taken all of
its indirect and direct prerequisites
this is called a topological sort
again the sorting word comes from the
motivation of thinking of there being a
path as like a less than or equal to
relation so we're sorting things in
order of increasing size 1801 would be
in this case a smallest element in six
8:57 our biggest in this list of
elements a chain is kind of technically
literally a thing called the dual of an
anti chain a chain is a sequence of
subjects that must be taken in order
that is these are subjects where for any
two of them you know which one has to
come first that is for between any two
of them there is a path in one way or
the other of course it's a dag so they
can't be paths in both directions so a
chain is simply a set of comparable
elements which implies that there's an
order in which they have to be taken so
here are some chains on the this one was
shown pictorially is a vertical chain
with five courses in it here's a verdict
here's a vertical chain of four and not
all of them are vertical here's a chain
where you have to take 1801 before you
take 1803 before you take six double oh
four so they form a chain it's important
to realize that this is a chain with
five subjects in it but a chain doesn't
have to have every possible element that
could be in it it's still a chain even
if it's only got these three subjects
because there's a path from 802 to six
double oh four in a path from six double
of four to six eight five seven but
maximum length chains chains that are as
full as possible are important
theoretically and so this in particular
is a maximal length chain the the
longest chain here is of length five now
it's not the only one there's another
chain of length five here if you look
for it here but the no chain is of
length longer than five and there is one
of length five and that leads us to the
question of how many terms is it
necessarily going to take to graduate
well we
saw that you can graduate in five and
but given that there's a maximum chain
of length five it means that you can't
do it in fewer because those five
courses have to be taken and
consecutively
each the third has to be taken in a term
after the first who have been taken the
second has to be taken after the first
if you have a chain of any size actually
the number of terms that graduate has to
be at least as big as that chain which
means it has to be at least as many
terms as a maximum size chain so five
terms are necessary and we saw using our
minimal strategy of being greedy that
you can always do it in maximum chain
lengths so five are also sufficient this
is providing that you can take an
unlimited number of subjects per term
remember our strategy to graduate in
five terms was to take as many subjects
as we possibly could each term so
there's the sufficient way to take
subjects to graduate in five terms and
of course one consequence is that in my
second term freshman year I was taking
five subjects cause it was possible but
that leaves me with a kind of heavily
loaded term compared to here's a term
with two subjects and there's a term
with only one subject in the at the very
end so it's possible in fact to somewhat
adjust the term load let's just shift
taking 1802 to the third term that's
perfectly feasible to do that because I
will have satisfied all the
prerequisites of 1802 after the first
term but I don't have to take it in the
second term let's shift it off so now
I've lightened the load in the second
term to four subjects somewhat
increasing the load I had to do it
somewhere in the third term to three
subjects so now I have to take no more
than four subjects a term and as a
matter of fact if you fiddle you can
actually find out graduating stressed or
a schedule in which you can only take
three subjects per term and we will
examine what's the minimum number of
subjects per term in the next segment